okay for people joining this livestream
we are talking about an application of
our Sparkle capabilities and graph
databases to wiki data ah all right
so external identifier as a general
mechanism for dealing with outside
identifiers such as do eyes correct yes
and the second argument here of external
identifier is what is the external is a
string representing the external systems
specification is that right not
necessarily a string but typically yes
what's the third argument here the third
optional argument is about metadata and
if there's a label property it's used
for format this is from entities because
entities received a formatting from
outside while external identifies
embedded metadata this is an important
and deliberate distinction okay I think
this a little bit bold here by the way
in terms of the formatting um okay the
labels are no link the URL but they said
understand this you can click into their
blue box on the label and it opens the
you are
this blue box yes but also the D the DOI
that means certain identifier types have
a base URL or a ul template associated
with them when we said a link can be
created for convenience okay so in I
click I click the name there but if I
click the thing that says wiki data ID
nothing happens it's just that part
that's active is that right yes because
for usability I like being able to click
twice on the type to highlight the whole
blue box and then copy and paste it okay
fair enough okay so this is so in
external identify their various
properties is that correct and such as
URL so right yes internally it's a your
template that's filled with ID okay I
understand but that so somewhere in the
definition so to add an external
identifier to add a type of external
identify what do you do is there a way
of registering a new external identifier
is that hard code or is there intended
to be a repository one day of external
identifiers templates or something or
what for now for now we have a curated
list that's going to be expanded and we
have to consider how we register new
ones what what services does an external
identifier provide an external identify
all by itself not for instance there
might be one organization that defines
this identifier and a couple of other
organizations that actually store them
so there's no one to one correspondence
between them that's why for instance
labels of certain things have to be
embedded in the external identify
because there's no canonical way for
retrieving them so okay I saw this
interesting example recently of a
collection of sites I think there's some
kind of fan sites about um
something other video games or something
where people generate IDs for things and
then they're essentially a volunteer
curators who knit together different IDs
for the same thing that people are
produced I know that was sort of an
interesting model for how to deal with
producing a large number of different I
mean you know we don't have that that if
we were to produce you know private
identifies for things there's a question
how they get message together I mean
this is different this external
identifier is dealing with existing
pre-existing identifiers right in but
you
yeah okay well if a future project is to
allow the user to introduce and use
their own identifies and have some
prototype of that but that's way in the
future and not even included in this
review yet okay I understand but I mean
eventually one could imagine an external
identify repository and then that would
also define how to document all these
different external identifier cases but
for right now we'll probably just list
these on the Istana and five reference
page right various cases okay
okay all right so let's take a look then
here at where we're not seeing the
correct um but let's take a look at four
oh it did work if I really what it
worked fine here okay so that that works
this is on the twelve one prototype so
that thing URL
okay how do I get the raw string out of
this first
I don't think URL has any properties
uh okay oops
alright wiki data search
it's an unlocked or video search but for
wicked
it's using essentially the same syntax
what's using the same syntax is using
the same syntax as Wikipedia search yes
well if I the type of thing that you
want back a property or item as a rule
you
you
okay
you
one important feature is that each
values of this list
well hold on a second so why is that
list why's that not just a value because
neither in RDF nor in McKee data the
test constraint that would say the value
can only be singleton
so and there might be various different
values claimed by different people and
in this case we just throw the value but
later we'll see that we can also
retrieve the resources for each value
now to see how it's getting more
important or by Chuck by child you see
that usually so each X an identifier
typed yeah but this is so arid that this
is a very incomplete what the heck is
this I mean this is a book right yes I
don't understand I mean this is a book
by with three authors so there's a mess
as usual
how this why is the wicked data-id just
the world gravitation no the format of
the wiki data ideas gravitation whose
format
there's ours whose yes so our MIDI data
associates with each of their
identifiers a label and a description
and in each language that's why we have
a language option and well this
gravitation is their label for that ID
okay by the way can we please again not
have these be so bold it really doesn't
look right
do they also have images for some of the
stuff yes
that worth displaying in here are
probably not I mean if I if I take this
and I say now can I just look at a
property of this no and the reason is
that by just having that ID we don't
know yet in general where to look it up
and as a courtesy to Viki data we don't
want random functions to make requests
to the server so there should be an
explicit function with wicket ID and a
name to trigger a call to the wiki data
service well I don't understand I mean
so so we're using their service although
we could presumably have our owner of
these things right yes so there is
option currently a string that's called
Sparkle endpoint and there you can point
it to your own server okay that should
be by the way some kind of something
based just like we have blockchain based
and so on it should also be in Brad's
list of system servers
right
okay but so now how do I find out what
properties this ass can I say properties
here you can say all common Association
but but yeah I can add support for if
you say comma association the string
then you see what properties those
values correspond
can I say commentator set yes
you
so why is this for not formatting
there's a special property called entity
which parses that actually and
converting it to an expression checking
for malicious code so it's really
understand that this is our ID right
yeah someone and I don't know who
advocate data proposed that property and
was created and some people have been
filling that out and they're more than
18-thousand items that have this code
and we can take advantage of that and
well convert those wicked ideas to
entities using that property value okay
but I mean why isn't this formatting
like like our yellow entertain because
this is still a string okay but why
because the day
type of that property is just string dad
elated a quantity or item but we know
what that I mean we know what that's at
least supposed to be right we could make
an exception for that property and post
process whenever that week so yeah we
think we should do that but now in this
case okay by the way what's the order of
things that we're seeing in here
and there's no defined order if you say
all okay well maybe we should figure out
some some appropriate order thing that
you see here is that we don't have all
of those external identifiers of Vicky's
data yet and we probably won't have to
remember because they have links to over
4,000 external identifiers types and I
imagine that we would curate say 100
wait wait wait which which one do I not
see here well for instance the Google
box ID yeah you see it's an external
identifier but we haven't curated
that particular idea so the identifier
for this external identifier type is
again an external identifier I see okay
so if you have a cure just a string
okay so if we get this
that wasn't very helpful
you
on earth I'm how enough drivers select
us
how do I select this I don't know about
that I think if you right-click on it
and choose copy data to clipboard
don't unfortunate that we have to go
through all of this some wiki data data
stuff
you
okay
what is an IEEE international standard
name identifier you have one - I'm so
flattered
it's an ISO standard
you
you
you
you
now I mean in a case like this where we
have mapped that wiki data ID to an
entity of ours right what's the reason
to not just give our entity here because
the mapping will always be incomplete
and then we would have a heterogeneous
list how do I convert this to our entity
here you can say wiki data data of dead
singh comma entity okay so if I take
this here
you
you
you
this here and I say entity is that
correct yes that doesn't look quite
promising no then they haven't been
filled out but it should work for other
times time what are you talking about
filled out I don't understand they're
actually talking one is which the
vegetative community does they fill out
their property they were from language
and it occurred the other mapping is we
curate Vicky's data IDs for our entities
I hope we already did that I mean Alan
is Alan here sound sick today okay I can
answer that we have where we have about
half of people data has wiki data IDs
attached to them always an ongoing
process for all domains yeah
okay but so so if I picked a random
person here there's a decent chance that
they would have a a wiki data ID yes
yes well I'll show later and document
more entity integrations things this is
mostly pure Mickey data stuff in this
basic chapter okay
hope boy and this is a function that we
might not need that was the first idea
but later came up there's a better one
but the ideas that we have implicit
entity class like syntax to film that
just wiki data data again we what where
do you place those rules in the first
element yes that would be possible but I
I think we might need a wrapper to
distinguish that yes
having a clear maybe okay
okay
you
you
you
so this function with the long name
might be useful if the wiki data updated
meta information might be useful if you
have just the IDS and you want to format
them properly
it takes a list and can format multiple
IDs and it's way too many functions here
this is not some random packages can
have 3000 functions I mean the you know
we have to reduce the number of
functions
I don't know what the heck this is what
is this one
this one could be skipped good let's do
it what is it what is it doing it is
retrieving the label and description
before that item from beginner and it's
embedding it into the identifier
but in general we need such a function
like assuming of a list of Ronald K of T
rise automatically filling out would be
a total waste of time Zoe but we need
some functionality to fill it out
you
so here are the ideas that you can use
entities properties and implicit entity
classes whenever there's a corresponding
bigoted ID and this function that you
are evaluating no it's not working yet
because those alignments are not on
production yet because we need to align
but they they will be evaluated on the
wiki data service those queries
you
you
you
Oh
this is a mess I mean because yeah it's
a beautiful mess you like this well it
was lucky today is super super cool
especially if the data is no garbage
I'm already seeing things in here that
are directly useful to projects I'm
working on right now like that wiki data
graph I'm working on on project to see
how many people we have to add the
people data if we expand familial
relationships out and number of steps
and this is going to be directly helpful
for me there fair enough
you
you
let's see to the end of this okay so let
me let me see what happens if I if I
were to do
okay so if I would simply say wiki data
graph Albert Einstein to come in the
second argument say all but 40 megabyte
graph was also it could take a few
seconds but it should work
it's huge because already it's that one
you get a very dense craft that you can
barely read right well let's try
somebody more obscure um so let's try I
guess yeah this needs to be cleaned
somewhat
or obscure let's try
boy so now the embedded metadata comes
in very handy
but invalid master data when you hover
over there the tooltip the description
so in big data they have to rule that in
each language
the combination of label and description
needs to be unique why are we giving the
description and here as a parentheses or
something because this is not very
useful Iranian and that's this
well it depends on the context sometimes
this description might clutter sings too
much well we could give a piece of the
description with a dot dot
is still taking its time so this one
okay so that's a random biographical
article not so how do we tell if this is
a person
or a
or random biographical article
there's a property called instance off
and that points to some class indicated
okay
okay so here in this case the number of
results was over a thousand therefore
the labels are not being displayed
because they would be useless anyway and
there might have to be an option to
control that I don't know stab why this
got so dense there
when this is so this is one level but
that's just showing how I see this edge
label and the destination is that
correct yes
well so some of these are aligned to our
entities and some are not but we don't
know at this point which ones in which
although we could know
couldn't we we could say for that list
regulator data of that list commodity no
no no I'm not talking about that I'm
talking about in the display here some
of these we already know correspond to
our entities and some we do not correct
but yes but there might be time
consuming to do it well that is the
failure of Viki data because as Vicki
data has not alike their entities beside
the reverse we could try to look up in
our database which of them correspond to
yeah I would do that I mean why don't we
just create a database which is the
inversion of our mapping to wiki data
IDs so we can do this what - from entity
could do and that's a question later in
well but this should work as well I mean
unless this is just okay this is just
show the garbage that's a wiki data and
nothing else I mean that's which is what
you're suggesting here so this is just a
pure wiki data wrapper yes so my opinion
would be that whenever the function is
called wiki data something then only the
wiki data service consultant
you
all right let's Cape take a look here
what is this what the heck is this
so Vicki that doesn't store facts but
statements that is what someone has said
and those usually come this qualifiers
and references by default we just show
the value well that's a string is that
true or is it something else
is it a string or is it something else
that is actually stored no it's Francis
for quantity it's no I'm talking about
the whole thing I'm talking about if I
just want to return the whole thing
whatever is in wiki - what about water
boiling point how do I get that here oh
it's a graph okay so if I say all of
that third argument what do I get of
water
no of this right this doesn't mean
anything country okay what may but there
should be some way of getting everything
that is in wiki data associated with
that entity and property right yes that
is currently what statement format Costa
Association does or we could have
statement form it goes to all which
implies Association that's fine
okay
why is that taking so long
those colors are more complex it goes
around a lot of corners to retrieve all
of that information
note how all of those IDs are nicely
labeled that's incredibly complicated
query that spans multiple pages okay
Sparkle query which we automatically
generate yes
so this one is translated to a symbolic
sparkle and from there to a sparkle
string and then when the result comes
back it
I mean wiki data data is then adding
values because then I don't have to
indent that crazy sparkle query yes it
hides a lot of the complexity of the
data model of the key date good okay so
let's keep going here and then we're
going to loop back to the beginning
again
what is this so this is a quick overview
of the identifier types that we have so
this one hold the data statement of how
many identifies are of a given type
those are not the counts in Vica data
but those are statements that a store
that means someone claimed that there
are 190 million TI's I'm pretty sure
that correct
what does in various places and for some
there is no statement okay
what the heck is all the stuff well
that's just my code for generating this
nice table so this is not something that
would be exposed necessarily to the user
I don't do this I mean if we have dollar
external identifier types it's gonna be
a list of types this is a different yes
yes that's why it's in an internal
context it's not might be useful to have
dollar external identifier types but it
should just be the strings and this
should be dollar exit an identifier type
information or something yes fine I
suggest you change that so we can have a
dollar exit unidentified types that
actually is a reasonably civilized list
I think they still no identifiers
themselves should be entities in there
me associate properties who maintains
them how many there are and so on fine
sensible idea
I see so there's an entity type called
external identifier yes yep or extra
anyway uptight
you
so one question I had how we should name
those types which types
it was external identifier types let's
say I want to add an external identify
type for items in the German National
Library how should we all that type or
in the French National Library all I
know it has already has a name right no
I haven't curated any national libraries
yet that's why this question how should
we do that I don't know I don't know we
don't know what it's supposed to I mean
I don't understand that I mean it's like
a Library of Congress I mean there's an
accession number for the Library of
Congress or something it's not you're
talking about
yes okay so what Aaron what are those
called just for Tony says the Library of
Congress Authority ID there's also the
library Congress Control Number the lccn
okay which is the accession number for a
bibliographic record okay we can discuss
that internally and come up with a
proposal so so this one the first
chapter that you see here is about not
introducing the key data lookup but
instead we're using the entity class
syntax okay listen listen listen listen
listen this whole thing okay so look
let's zoom out for a moment okay look
okay so
have our own well-curated system for all
of the stuff
the question is wiki data has all kinds
of information in it some of which is
right so which is messy some which is
wrong some which aligns with what we
have some which doesn't and the question
is to what extent can we make this work
the same way and I just understand why
we can't make wiki data ID one of these
wiki data what is this thing again this
is an external identifier right
thing here okay so the great giant
Magellan telescope okay so I don't
understand why we can't make that work
you know using our standard syntax here
oh this is Austin let's enjoy let's take
another example
no no wait wait wait a second wait a
second wait a second wincing so if I
give a property here this does not
currently work right I mean the only
property that works here is something
like URL because this is an external
identifier object quote this isn't the
actual thing itself this isn't merely an
external identifier right yes okay so if
the type
wicked a tidy but say isbn-13 what would
the canonical call be which server would
you call tips but Stephen did this end
of pop it's just some syntactic sugar
for energy value I know
so what form is using the longer form
which longer form in the D value because
people want to use this and they don't
want to explain that in certain cases
look I don't know I mean okay the other
problem is that you've got this thing
about the fact that you don't have
single values you have lists because
everybody doesn't know what they're
actually you know what the actual value
is here I mean it like leasing spirit
that doesn't exist the single yeah we
also miss you so hold on hold on hold on
but I mean you know the obvious question
that comes to mind is you know the
trouble is there's a certain amount of
crud in wiki data there's good stuff in
this crud right I mean so you know for
example here I'm sure if I say control
equals overwhelmingly large telescope
we don't know what that is that's
surprising I'm pretty sure about over
there Mindy is not any linguistics
anybody has reasonably used well it is I
mean the extremely large telescope I
know is a thing how come that doesn't
and we have telescopes right it's called
ELT as I recall
we don't have that
something weird is going on here but
okay fair enough
large telescopes are not an exposed
entity claw entity type oh how come I
don't know
okay well I mean so my
about those external identifiers are
that they just are there to stand for
themselves and then there might be
different services that support a
different subset of identifiers types
let's say there might be an archive data
that well just supports those okay all
right all right all right listen listen
if we're gonna do this we need to have
these things visually look more
different form entities okay
yes this looks way too similar to
entities first of all that that boldface
doesn't help anything um I don't know
exactly how to do that maybe it started
lines around it I don't know but right
now these look like entities and people
will get confused so we have to figure
out a way to make them look less like
entities those seem saying it's all in
the right but
I mean then the second question is from
a curation point of view now that we
have nice easy access to this which we
we've had some access to it for ages you
know figuring out how to curate
everything that is worth curating here
which is more Aaron and Alan's issue
but presumably given that we now have
easy access here it will become easier
to do that
is that a true statement yes yes but
this temp is a little bit of easier like
when you said earlier biggie data has
been data but definitely is the case it
might be non-trivial to figure out
what's the right data Oh to be to be
sure yes of course but as far as walking
from our data to wiki data and back and
forth this this simplifies things for us
let's take a look here okay so I want to
come back to maybe I have an idea what
about we have I know it's not your
favorite function but people do use it
heavily system options what about having
in system options a subclass of option
that specifies the prefilled external
service to use for certain external
identifiers type and then the end of pop
would automatically go there and pick it
up why on earth would it be there
because it fits pretty well the
definition of what's in system options
um no it shouldn't be in system options
I mean if it's in something like that it
should be in some kind of I mean that's
much more like system servers and and so
on I mean it's just that system options
isn't quite the right place but what's
your point I mean your point is that
then which have that replace then end of
pop could be made well yes I understand
but we just agreed that we weren't gonna
treat these external identifiers as
entities but this doesn't mean we don't
want end of pop eunuch de vacas doesn't
imply it in any form um
okay a bit but then then this becomes
not an external identifier but some kind
of entity which is a little different no
no everything stays is it this okay just
that we would allows up there you
obligation but we already have the URL
sub value exactly that's something that
can be computed this also axis I know I
know I know
I'm the treasurer b-boy probably
botrytis off well we're trying to solve
it is the question is are we going to
pretend that these are like our entities
or not
right now if
Mattox is way different in the sense
that they always have lists as values
and weird stuff like that then maybe
it's better that we don't pretend that
they're like our entities see what I'm
saying
list argument then there might also be
some tendency to make those values from
entities more lists because no we're not
gonna do that no we've got a whole
system that's built not doing that right
so we're not gonna do that we're not
going to change our system because wiki
data happens to do something right so no
not in general but their properties
their own lists yes there are but not
every property returns a list right and
in this case every property returns a
list right that not correct it's correct
okay so you know a property like you
know a person's you know the rivers
discharge rate for us is a number that
you can compute you can add it to
something else right you can it doesn't
return a list right which would cause it
not to be able to be combined with other
things right
yes yes okay so I think
better okay so let's zoom out again for
a second okay so first thing is we got
to make these IDs look less like
entities if they are not in fact because
they're not in fact entities their IDs
now admit it does look somewhat
different here but I don't think it
looks different enough but okay that as
you say as a solvable problem
now here okay so this is Auto converting
only potentially working on server
current okay but this is using our
mapping from our entities to wiki Gator
IDs correct yes
okay now meanwhile we will have
something else which is a mapping from
wiki data IDs to our entities which
presumably
I mean what let's see uh yeah I mean
that could perfectly well be a sub value
of the wiki data of the external
identifier right and should be am I
making sense yep yes
also conceptually I would find form
entity to entity the better choice that
will be fine but I think the sub value
entity could also work yeah okay so from
entity no wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait from what does from entity do
right now so from entity it's I'm an
entity to thank you has save on some
language data it goes through the
corresponding symbols okay but so from
entity unless we had a second argument
from from entity no I do we want that I
mean to hold on hold on hold on to
entity needs a second argument because
we might go to different entity types
for one thing okay but so the idea would
be to entity of an external identifier
with one argument would attempt to go to
the corresponding and today right right
okay no there will not be multiple ones
no that will not okay but that's a
question of dealing with our hierarchy
which we are getting to separately which
hopefully you're gonna work on real soon
right Tony and that that's that's not
going to be a separate issue there I in
this concrete stage but in generalizing
Tony's right there isn't there will be
not a one-to-one mapping because the
ontology is are different I think that
mess but it's not our we didn't do it
yeah but to entity we could just use the
second argument of the entity type
you're looking for if there's no I agree
I agree I agree
I just think it should try to return a
single thing
so from entity is normally going to or
from language
ah
you know to a pure wolf language
citation if there is one correct
and I would have thought that what we
would want is something more like
external identifier now okay the first
argument of the external identifier
I see this would look way too it said we
had a design previously for going from
our introduced to an external identifier
what is that design
right remember that this is what Ellen
sent you
well I don't remember reading it but so
I'll go find it because it's in my notes
entities could have a property called
wicket-gate ID and as BN look no no
because we'll have hundreds of those
okay let's see I have something from
last year from the course exactly a year
ago
that's about phone numbers why is it
about phone numbers did this ever get
done
did this get done I don't think so
you
okay
you
you
I see
so the idea here was to have the
external identifier have its
identify a system
but that's sub casing inside an external
identifier which is not quite what
you've done right yes
did you see this note so not yes I have
looked at them okay in detail but this
is the best design I could come up with
based on door okay okay okay so let's go
through what your design is relative to
this design um
can you really comment on this design
cuz I really would like to understand
why we're not
um
you
and whatever happened to the
bibliographic items stuff we never did
it because there came all the priorities
along external ones fair enough we
should give this phone number thing is
anybody taking notes or project managing
or nothing I mean this phone number
thing we should give that to Johan and
see what he can find someone to do this
yeah this shouldn't be very hard
um and similarly with personal name we
should get both of these done they're
both
they're both worthwhile things to do
okay so let's come back here to the sole
question about
so I'm I'm a little confused let's start
at the beginning again okay
so this is all good but the question is
how do we go from an entity to the
external identifier
you know is it the case that what we do
but because it's always so I agree
that's a question to be asked but it's
in some sense Metro silver take another
one one did you ice we don't have after
hundred ninety million between two think
you corresponding entity fine but we
certainly do for wiki data right yeah
okay so let's take a look at what we do
in the case where we're converting from
our entities to some external identifier
do we believe that that mapping is
one-to-one
not necessarily different ontologies can
resolve items in different ways for
instance in Mickey data there might be a
single person which has 20 identify as a
musicbrainz because this same person
access different artists so in general
there okay okay
additionally it's not it's not unheard
of for you know these external sources
to have duplicate entities just like we
do occasionally to identify errs for the
same person and that is a fixable
problem on their end but it's still
probably have to deal with I think it
was there a couple even famous
physicists to change genders or twice a
placenta Tannis different built-ins
giving do eyes have duplicates sometimes
the same document has two different do
eyes which isn't supposed to happen but
does yeah because publishers while
selling to Tana to the next one day
three indexed okay um okay so look one
thing we need clearly okay so first
question I mean okay look first
statement Toni this is all very nice
okay
I'm just first question is is this going
to be a package or is this going to be
a built-in set of things external
identifier is certainly going to be a
built-in thing um if you have Wikipedia
data we could have wiki data yeah I'm
sure
okay but we should try to minimize the
number of functions here so I mean in
yes you can already drop to the updated
information indeed look up okay
lose any functionality result the wiki
data graph is so nice we have to have it
yeah as their own fountain or I think so
I mean unless unless we had that be a
third argument to wiki data data 20 and
I discussed it but Tony don't like this
idea yeah because that might need to be
graph options and parameters no it's not
easy to have integrated into a wiki data
did although it is consistently thought
of as a wiki data return type right
people trust and have some kind of medal
or studying or whatever option - the
whole thing - well I mean it just is
it's just a random other options that
you could add to wiki data data that
would style the graph correct which
doesn't seem that horrifying I mean it's
a little bit unfortunate to not be able
to document the wiki data data options
because they might add some graph
display options well my only be
dependent on the third argument Yeah
right
right
how you spell is the wiki data graph
I mean it's impressive to look at but
how useful is it if I were to try to
extract things from the scruff could I
do it
yes so this graph stores in a meaningful
way it's data so you can retrieve it
just and connect certain things it's not
just nice to look at but
programmatically how can you do that I
mean without graph theory operations
well I didn't include it because this
notebook is already too thick but I have
some functionality no but is it new
functionality that you've invented or is
it just standard functionality using the
property mechanism to store their
relevant information think there's no
but Steve knows you could do fine show
this pass and all this stuff no rice
node and no Tex decrees end zone yeah
but could I extract the fact that you
know you know Elsa was the most ignored
child or something here for now that's -
what do you mean by this most ignored I
don't know by by by having fewest links
or something
I don't know I mean could I could I find
that node name is that the node name
what is the actual structure of this
graph it's a graph object and you can
apply each list and vertex s to get
started looking at what that is
and lendable
just and then you have properties in the
sense of system backtick property which
has been renamed all right
that's no longer called property
you know that right I was not me is off
it's been renamed
supposed to be changed for 12.1
because we're getting rid of that stupid
property thing so as you can see here in
those edges you don't see yet what the
property was that created as X so this
is also stored in the graph where I few
seconds please
okay you can probably just make into it
form of the closet and you see what
Cindy I know I understand okay okay all
right I understand well okay look
provisionally let's assume we're gonna
have this function so you could say
property value off a list I understand I
get it I get that I hate that function
it was introduced in some way that
evaded designer of you several years ago
and it has subsequently been killed
um I should check that that um
um
Stephen any bigger things I would have
to go to another meeting and I think 20
has some ideas what to do um no I think
this is pretty nice I think we should
look at it I mean unfortunately we if we
had probably another half hour we could
nail this completely um
let's not make the trenches I think
might be easier going from there all
right okay fine it's really nice though
it's really nice and hopefully we can
use it to um I mean hopefully I don't
know what um yeah we do need to get this
thing going from our entities to our
entities straightened out ah that seemed
to me one of the most easy ones that
pure mechanics fair enough
and then I would be interested to know
you know what can we really I mean I
obviously we've been using things from
here but as as Aaron says it's very hard
to know what's correct what's not
correct
um and so on
yeah well fair enough fair enough
um okay all right sounds good um thank
you thanks okay see y'all soon bye-bye